ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BAKER BORJA BRADFORD CUT BY AT
CORTES. SALLY DODD IRAN'S
EGGMAN LASER GONZALEZ GROSS
HERTZBERG WASTE. HURTADO JONES
CAN. WHERE LEYVA BIGELOW. MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH
SAM FOURTEEN. ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER. STERN I'M BURKE WHITE
HOUSE SKI YEAH. WELL. SENATORS
A CORE IS PRESENT. WITH THE AND
ARE BEYOND RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLAYWRITE. WE WILL
LEAD IN THIS MORNING VICE PAN
AFTER WHICH REMAINS. WE WILL BE
LED AND PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR MEN. THANK
MAN PRESS- I THE FOLLOWING.
NEARLY GOT A CHANCE FROM CALL
YOU OPENING YOU TO CONTINUE TO
RENEW OLD MAY GOD OF COMFORT
YOU DURING TO SEE THE WORLD
THROUGH GOD EYES. MADE GOD OF A
BY OF FIRM YOU LETTING YOU TALK
DEEPER. MADE A OF EMBRACE YOU
AND CIRCLING IN THE OF GODS
HOME. MAY GOD OF HOPEFULNESS
BLESSED. ENCOURAGE YOU WITH THE
FREE OF. THE GOD OF WELCOME
INVITE YOU TRYING YOU NEARER TO
THE FULLNESS OF GOD EXPRESSION
IN THE- BIG GUY WHO IS PRESENT
BE WITH YOU. AWAKENING YOU TO%
GOD AND ALL THINGS. ALL PEOPLE
AND ALL MOMENT. GOD BE WITH YOU
TODAY AND- A MAN. SUCH. I AFTER
THE SPRAY- IN SINCE WE'VE LAST
NIGHT ON THIS ON MY- ACTUALLY
FOLLOWING- THERE ACTUALLY WERE
THAT OUT- FOR NORTH STATION
CAUGHT STOP EIGHT EIGHT THE
DOCTOR THE INCREASE AND- HATE
INCIDENTS A PEACE. AND IN THAT
VERY EVENING- EIGHT PEOPLE WERE-
MURDERED BASS MURDERED AND- I
HAD THREE DOES. INCLUDING SIX
ASIAN. AND SO AS WE GATHERED
TODAY TO CONVENE AGAIN THIS
MORNING I DIDN'T WANT TO- FOR A
MOMENT FOR US TO REFLECT THAT
AND FIRST AND ON I WANT TO PASS
IT ON TO MEN FOR A FEW WORDS IN
THEN HELP WITH TAKE A MOMENT OF.
IN THEIR MEMORY ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU DR PAN- AS DR PAYMENT SIX
OF THESE WERE ASIAN WOMEN THIS
WAS A TARGET ACT HATE A LOT OF
FOCUS HAS BEEN ON THE SHOOT AND
HIS BUT I DON'T THINK ENOUGH
THAT HAS BEEN TO THE LIVES OF
THE- I EACH OF THESE WOMEN WAS
A C. EIGHT FIVE WEEKS OF THE
MORE. THEY IN THE CENTER THERE
AND COMMUNITY AND I ASKED THAT
AS WE TAKE OUR MY TO SIGN WE
REFER ON THESE LOS LIE AND
HARPER AND ANGER THAT THEIR ARE.
AND I LIKED IT SENATE BACK TO
TALK CAN'T. SO AND PRESENT AND
WE CAN WE CAN TAKE A TAKE A OF.
AND THEN OF. THE EIGHTY WERE
KILLED INCLUDING THE SIX A
WOMEN AND ALL- THE OTHER A WHO
HAPPENED. ALSO DIED- BECAUSE OF
HEY DIRECTED TOWARD DETACHED ME
THANK YOU. WE WILL TAKE A
MOMENT SILENCE PLEASE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- I GUESS THAT
SENTIMENT FOR THE PLEDGE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
PLEDGING ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN AND SENATOR MAN FOR
THE MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR THE
VICTIMS. OF THIS TRAGEDY.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE THE
SENATOR EARLY MORNING AND
MELENDEZ PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
SO GOOD MORNING SENATORS AND
WELCOME. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN. SENATOR SKINNER. WE
CAN JUST TAKE PICS YES SENATOR
SKINNER IS READY- PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND AFTER
LEADING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGETS SENATOR SKINNER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. YES THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SB
NINETY FIVE ESTABLISHES COVERT
NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FEDERAL RULES THAT ALLOW FOR.
EMPLOYERS TO UTILIZE PAYROLL
TAX CREDITS FOR THE SICK LEAVE
AND SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS WITH MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES. TO
PROVIDE UP TO TWO WEEKS OR
EIGHTY HOURS OF SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE FOR CORPORATE
NINETEEN RELATED REASONS. THIS
INCLUDES EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO QUARANTINE OR
ISOLATION TUTOR COKE NINETEEN.
FOR CARING FOR A FAMILY MEMBER
WHO IS SUBJECT TO COPE NINETEEN
QUARANTINE OR ISOLATION. WHO IS
ATTENDING A COURT BID NINETEEN
VACCINE APPOINTMENT OR
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS FROM THE
VACCINE TO PREVENT THEM FROM
WORKING OR WHO ARE CARING FOR A
CHILD. WHO SCHOOL OR PLACE OF
CARE IS CLOSED DUE TO COVERT
NINETEEN. THIS BILL PARS
RETROACTIVELY TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WILL HAS
A- END DATE SO IT IT ONLY
REMAINS IN EFFECT UNTIL
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WHICH IS THE DATE
THAT THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS
THAT EMPLOYERS CAN UTILIZE FOR
THIS PURPOSE- ACT CONCLUDE. THE
BILL WAS A TO ADDRESS CA THAT
WERE RAISED IN. THAT IT ONLY UP
TO BUSINESSES WITH MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE IN. 72% OF
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESSES HAVE
FEWER THAN FIVE EMPLOYEES AND
SO THIS DOES NOT MANDATE THIS
ON. THOSE EMPLOYERS HOWEVER
EMPLOYER MAY TAKE IT OF IF SO
CHOOSE TO BECAUSE THE TAX IS
AVAILABLE. THE PAYROLL TAX
PRETTY S OF TO ANY AND IN.
HOWEVER ARE BILL ONLY ME TO FOR
EMPLOYERS OF FIVE IN ABOUT. SO
WITH THE CHANGES HAVE BEEN MADE
THE BILL STILL PER SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT FOR WORK. AND THE MID
OF IN OUR STATE. AND MEMBERS
WITHOUT I ASK YOUR BOATS.
SENATOR NIELSEN. MEMBERS DONALD
SENATE I URGE A NO VOTE THIS IS
PAUL. NOW I'LL MANY YEARS AGO
THAT THE BY AND A- THE NET
DOCUMENT IT'S A POLICY DOCUMENT
EQUALLY IF NOT MORE SO. THAT'S
OKAY I GET BUT IS MAJOR. IN
ORDER TO THE OBJECT IN THAT BUS
IN THE PROCESS NOT A HAS BEEN
AND IN THE BUDGET RELAY TO THE
BOX AND CAL. THAT IS A MILLION.
FOR MORE THAN THIS BILL OVER.
OF OUR CAN. JUST LAST YEAR'S
FROM CALL HAVE BEEN LAW INTO
YOUR OFFICE FROM AGREED.
CITIZENS BY EDT YEAH WE'RE NOT
TO DEAL WITH I HOPE NOT. THAT I
WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH THAT IS
TO THE IN BY. THEREFORE I
WOULD- URGE AND NO ON THE BILL.
THERE ANY FURTHER. OR. TO
CENTER GROVE I'M SORRY MY PA.
THE OKAY MADAM HAS I UNDER
THERE'S A GOOD ON THE GLASS. I
TO RISING UP OF THE BILL I
SEVERAL TO THE BUDGET- ONE
THING THAT I IS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAID THAT IT WAS A ONE
TO ONE RECENT FOR BUSINESS ARE
TO ONE CREDIT AND IT'S NOT
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OFFERS- TO
DOLLARS AND SOME CASES
SPECIFICALLY THE CASE THAT THE
BY CHAIR JUST MENTION. AND THEN
THE STATE CALIFORNIA IS
CONTROLLERS PER DAY A TAX
CREDIT THE STATE FOR FIVE
ELEVEN DOLLARS SO THERE'S THREE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN THEY HAVE TO
COME FROM AND IT'S FROM GOING
TO CAMP THE STRUGGLE BUSINESS
TO MAKE A THE OTHER IS THAT IF
DON'T HAVE A TAX. AT THE END OF
THE YEAR. AND YOU DON'T GET A
TAX CREDIT MEAN GET A REFUND.
SO ON THE LIABILITY ONLY GOOD
IF YOU- OWE TAXES. WHEN YOU GET
THIS TAX CREDIT THE OTHER THING
IS. BUSINESS THAT ARE STILL.
AND ALL OF OUR DISK. LIKE
BUSINESS. THAT ARE. BIZ OWNERS.
THAT HAVE THIRTEEN- TOOK ALL
SHE- IN THESE BILLS. ABOUT THE
TWENTY. PER 224% THRESHOLD.
THESE BUSINESS HAVE TO LAY OUT
THAT CAN. OUT RIGHT NOW. AND
PAY THOSE EMPLOYEES THEY
WOULDN'T GET ANY MONEY. IF ANY
MANY. IF THE LIABILITY DOES
EXIST REFI. UNTIL THE END OF
THE YEAR. THE RIGHT TRACK. IS
X. CAN. SO BASED. YOU HAVE. A
THAT IF THIS PASSES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S. IT IT'S GOING TO
READ TO. MAKE BUSINESS. PAY
FOR. LEASE THAT STARTED JANIE
FIRST. AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
LABOR SECTION TWO TWO SIX AND
YOU LOOK AT THE BIO. THAT OCCUR-
BASED ON. AN INACCURATE WEIGHT
STAY. AND NOT. DURING THAT TIME
FOR. THERE NO LANGUAGE THIS.
THAT STOPS THE SOME. FOR BEING
SO. FOR UP. MEANING THAT IN IF
THEY GO BACK TO PAY SOME. JEAN
FIRST THROUGH JAN. FOURTH IN
THIS PARTICULAR PIECE ALLEGE.
TO SOMEBODY. TAKE TWO WEEKS OFF.
THEY HAVE ENACT HER WAIT. FROM
THAT. FOR WHICH IS A VIOLATION
OF POPULAR WILL CREATE MANY.
PLAN FOR THESE EMPLOYER THAT
ARE STILL STRUGGLING. TO
RECOVER FROM THE GOVERNOR SHUT
DOWN AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
OPERATE THEIR BUSINESS. SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT EMPLOYEES ARE PAID-
YOU KNOW I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THERE'S A SAFETY NET UNDER
EMPLOYMENT BUT OBVIOUSLY IN THE
IN THE PLANNING. DEPARTMENT
CAN'T GET BENEFITS OUT TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE. OFF WORK. THE
EMPLOYERS PAY FOR IN THE FIRST
PLACE IT'S 1100% EMPLOYER
FUNDED. I WISH THERE WAS A
MECHANISM IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS
EFFECTIVE SO THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T
HAVE LOSS OF WAGES. BUT THIS IS
NOT THE ANSWER. BECAUSE THIS
RETROACTIVITY IN THIS BILL IS
DEVASTATING. IF YOU'VE NEVER
BEEN TO A PAGA. LAWSUIT IT'S
ABSURD. IF YOU HAVE A PAYCHECK
FOR. PAYCHECK THIS IS WEEK DEAN
SAID ONE OR WEAKENED DEAN SAID
EIGHT. AND YOU PAY WEEK. THAT'S
A VIOLATION TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS PER PAYCHECK PER
EMPLOYEE. IN A TRACTOR AFTER
FOR YEARS. SO IS A- HORRIBLE
PEACEABLE. WHEN YOU LOOK IT
FROM ON THE GO. AN OPERA. YEAH
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE TAKING CARE OF
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
IN NOT BEING ABLE TO GO TO WORK
AND WE WANT TO STOP THE SPREAD.
BUT THIS BILL IS NOT THE ANSWER
FOR OUR STRUGGLING BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE IN EVERY ONE
OF OUR DISTRICTS. AND SO I
WOULD REQUEST IN ABOUT. SENATOR
DRAWS ON. THANK YOU MANAGER I
RISE TO SUPPORT IS BEING FIVE
AND I ALL OF THE THAT WE INTO
IT I AM CAN AS OTHERS ARE WITH
THE EXEMPTS. ACCORDING TO EDT
DATA ABOUT 90% OF CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS HAVE LESS THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES AN ESTIMATED FOUR
MILLION WORKERS WOULD BE EXEMPT
FROM THE PAID SICK LEAVE UNDER
THE THRESHOLD OF THIS BILL.
ASCENTIAL WORKERS ARE BEING
LEFT OUT SMALL BUSINESSES
EMPLOY THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS THESE ARE OFTEN
LOW WAGE WORKERS THE PANDEMIC
IS NOT OVER LOW WAGE FRONT LINE
WORKERS ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
ANY OTHER BENEFITS AVAILABLE TO
THEM IT MAKES NO SENSE OF THESE
VULNERABLE WORKERS MUST WORK
WHEN THEY ARE SICK. WHAT WE ARE
TRYING DESPERATELY TO GET OUT
OF THIS PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES RECEIVED AN
ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN PPP LOANS IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE STATE HAS FUNDED TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS A FOUR
FOLD INCREASE OVER THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION WE PROVIDED IN
EARLIER RELIEF. WE MUST FIGURE
OUT HOW TO PROVIDE THE MOST
BASIC PROTECTION OF BEING ABLE
TO STAY HOME WHILE SICK DURING
THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU MENTION.
SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THIS IS A TOUGH BILL IN
A LOT OF WAYS IT WAS TOUGH FOR
ME AND I SHARES OF THE CONCERNS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD- MENTIONED- ON THE
OTHER HAND IT IS GOOD POLICY WE
DON'T WANT SICK WORKERS COMING
INTO WORK ARE FACING THAT TOUGH
DECISION. BETWEEN MISSING A
PAYCHECK OR LOSING THEIR JOBS
OR ALTERNATIVELY COMING IN SICK
WITH A COLD IT IN SPREADING IN
THEIR WORKPLACES AND LET'S BE
CLEAR AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES DESCRIBED MANY OF THESE
WORKERS ARE FRONT LINE THEIR
LOW INCOME AND THEY NEED THIS
JOB RIGHT NOW AND WE NEED TO
ENACTED POLICY AT THE SAME TIME
I HAVE FOR LIKE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SMALL
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT.
ABOUT HOW TOUGH IT IS RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE STRUGGLING THEY ARE
BARELY HANGING ON MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE IN FACT GONE
UNDER- AND TO ADD ON MORE
BURDENS TO SMALL BUSINESSES-
JUST IS ANOTHER IT'S A BIG BLOW
RIGHT NOW AND SO- I WAS TORN ON
THIS BUT I DID SUPPORT IT IN
COMMITTEE I WILL SUPPORT IT
AGAIN TODAY- I WAS HEARTENED TO
LEARN ABOUT SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAD
MADE I KNOW THIS WAS THE
PRODUCT OF A LOT OF HARD WORK
IN NEGOTIATION. I WAS ALSO VERY
PLEASED TO LEARN OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COVER ONE TO
ONE I'M A GOOD AMOUNT OF THE
COSTS INCURRED BY BUSINESSES IN
THESE TWO THINGS KIND OF TOOK
THIS IN IN FAVOR OF AN AYE VOTE
SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK MY
COLLEAGUES AND I VOTE ON THIS.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MATT
JUST WENT AWRY A BUSINESS OWNER
AND SEVEN WHO TALKS TO SMALL
BIZ OWNERS EVERY DAY BOB BE
OPPOSING THIS IS THIS GIVES YOU
TAX. AND I DON'T KNOW IF
EVERYBODY'S AWARE BUT YOU A TAX
CUTS ONLY GOOD IF YOU MAKE
MONEY. THINK ABOUT THAT IF YOU
DON'T MAKE MONEY YOU DON'T NEED
A TAX CREDIT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
PAY TAXES IF YOU LOSE MONEY. I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MANY. SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE. HAVE PUT THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS INTO JUST STAYING
ALIVE. AND LOOK I HAVE
EMPLOYEES IN AND WE WERE CLOSE
WITH THEM AND IF ONE WAS SICK
FROM YOU KNOW THERE THERE WAS
THERE WAS LOANS FOR PP THERE
WAS LOANS BUT THAT'S TO KEEP
THEM SAFE. I JUST WANT TO SHARE
WITH IT THERE'S A LOT OF
BUSINESS OUT THERE THAT ARE
GOING TO ARE GOING TO AT THIS
IS RETROACTIVE. BY THE WAY SO
THAT MEANS YOU PAID OUT. BEFORE
YOU GET IT BACK IF YOU MAKE
MONEY. AND THERE'S A HOT
THERE'S A- I WATCHED WHICH ARE.
THIS THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
ARE ON A SHOESTRING RIGHT NOW
SO I WAS LIKE YOU TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION THAT YOU
MUST UNDERSTAND THAT. YOU HAVE
TO MAKE MONEY FOR TAX CUTS EVER
GET TO YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. SENATOR ROB. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT TO TRY
TO CORRECT THE BUT APPEARS TO
BE A MISUNDERSTANDING HERE ON
THE FLOOR. AS TO THE FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR THE BILL AND SOME
OF YOU KNOW I ASKED A QUESTION
ABOUT THE FUNDING WHEN THIS
BILL WAS FIRST. OPERA BUT THIS
ISSUE WAS FIRST PROPOSED. IN
THE FUNDING MECHANISM IS A
PAYROLL TAX CREDIT THOSE OF YOU
WHO DO HAVE BUSINESSES KNOW
THAT THE RECORDER YOU REMIT
PAYROLL TAXES TO. AMONG OTHERS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH
YOUR PAYROLL TAX RETURNS ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS. AND THE BILL
AND THE LEAVE IS FUNDED THROUGH
THE PAYROLL TAX CREDIT SO IF
YOU. IF YOU HAVE LEAVE THAT
ATTACH IS TO YOUR BUSINESS
BECAUSE EMPLOYEES ARE TAKING IT
THE COST OF THAT LEAVE IS
DEDUCTED FROM THE PAYROLL TAX
LIABILITY THAT YOU OWE THE
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT QUARTER. IT
IS NOT AN INCOME TAX CREDIT
WHICH OF COURSE WOULD CAUSE A
PROBLEM PARTICULARLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESS PARTICULARLY IN A
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WHERE
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT. SOME OF
THEM DON'T HAVE ANY INCOME. AND
MANY OF THEM HAVE IF NOT MOST
OF THEM HAVE INCOME TAX LOSSES
BUT REMEMBER THIS IS A
QUARTERLY PAYROLL TAX RETURN
ISSUE. IT'S HANDLED ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS AND YOU DO NOT
PAY THE GOVERNMENT IF YOU'RE
PUTTING THAT MONEY TO YOUR
EMPLOYEES SO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR HOPE THAT CORRECTS THE
MISUNDERSTANDING ON THE FLOOR.
SENATOR DODD. YEAH I JUST WANT
RIGHTS- IN CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE- WE
LOOK AT THIS BILL EARLY ON AND
THAT WAS A REAL CONCERN ADD TO
A NUMBER OF US IN WE DID FIND
OUT THAT THE PAYROLL TAXES YOU
CAN TAKE THE PAYROLL TAXES
CORRECT CREDIT PAYROLL TAXES
THAT ALLEVIATED BIG PROBLEM- IN
MY MIND THE SECOND THING ABOUT
THE PAGA HILL ISSUE AS IT
RELATES TO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. IS THAT YOU HAVE A RIGHT
TO CURE AND THAT THE ULTIMATELY
THE RIGHT TO CURE ISN'T WHEN
THIS BILL PASSES THE RIGHT TO
CURE IS. WHEN YOU GET A
COMPLAINT. WHEN AND IF YOU GET
A AS EVEN. AGAIN YOUR BIZ AND
THEN YOU HAVE THAT CLOSE STARTS.
TICKING FROM THAT POINT IN
TIME. IS THIS THE BUSINESS LIKE
SCHOOL BILL IS THE BEST BILL
THAT WE'VE EVER PRODUCED OUT OF
THIS HOUSE I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT. BUT I THINK THIS IS A
COMPROMISE BETWEEN TWO. MANY
MANY ENTITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
WORKING REALLY REALLY HARD TO
TRY TO CRAFT THE BEST. POSSIBLE
LEGISLATION HERE I'D LIKE TO
TAKE MY- YOUR HAT OFF TO- OUR
BUDGET TEAM AND STAFF FOR
WORKING SO HARD ON THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOOK.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE YES SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
JUST HAVE A PARLIAMENTARY
ENQUIRING ON THIS BILL I
NOTICED US SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY FIVE- IS AUTHORED ON
FILE I'LL FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER IF YOU FLIP THROUGH THE
OUR FILE AND GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SIX I BELIEVE.
THEY HAVE AB EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
IS AUTHORED BY THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO THE QUESTION IS
THIS- POLICY- BILL OR IS THIS A
BUDGET BILL BECAUSE ACCORDING
TO THE RULES OF BUDGET BILLS
BETTER BUDGET BILLS NEED TO BE
AUTHORED BY THE BUDGET IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT WE MIGHT BE IN
VIOLATION OF THE JOINT RULES
THAT STATE THAT BUDGET BILLS
MAY ONLY BE AUTHORED BY THE
SENATE. COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW.
THE ANSWER IS
THAT THIS IS- THIS IS A BUDGET
BILL. AND THIS WAS INTRODUCED
BEFORE THE COMMITTEES WERE
ESTABLISHED AND THAT HEADING
IS- IT WAS NOT CHANGED IN THE
AND IN THE ASSEMBLY IT THIS IS
A BUDGET BILL. LEON I RAISE
THIS OF CARLA BECAUSE THE
PUBLIC HAS THE RIGHT TO REVIEW
WHAT WE'RE DOING ON POLICY
ISSUES AND WHEN WE- ARE KIND OF
SIDESTEPPING I UNDERSTAND WHEN
THE QUILL BID- SITUATION. BUT I
WOULD NORMALLY MOVE ON THAT WE
TAKE THIS THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE BECAUSE OF THE
VIOLATION OF THE JOINT RULES
THAT WE STILL OPERATE UNDER
ADOPTED LAST YEAR AND NOT
CHANGE THIS YEAR. DUE TO THE
TIMING THAT WE HAVE ON ALL OUR
COMMITTEES I'M GOING TO PASS
THIS TIME WHAT I WOULD ASK THE
IN THE FUTURE THAT WE FOLLOW
THE RULES AND IF WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT THAT THIS BODY
IS ALERTED TO THAT. AT THAT
MOMENT BECAUSE WHAT ARE THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM- SITTING. IN
FRONT OF ME. HE MENTIONED THAT
THE IS A- IS WE CAN. TO DEBATE
ON THIS FLOOR IS PAULA. THAT IS
BEING PUT THROUGH A BY BILL A
TRAILER BILL AND WE WILL GET
INTO THAT LATER IN THE SET. AND
I THINK THE- MIDDLE THE POWER.
I UNDERSTAND WE ARE OPERATING
UNDER COALBED WE'RE MAKING
EXCEPTIONS AND I THINK THAT
THAT NEEDS TO BE VERY CLEAR.
BECAUSE WHEN WE GO BACK TO OUR
DISTRICTS. ESPECIALLY ON A BILL
LIKE THIS IS VERY CONTROVERSIAL
VERY IMPACTFUL TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE PEOPLE THAT
GENERATE THE REVENUES THAT RUN
THIS WHOLE SHOW. ARE THEY NEED
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE. SO WITHOUT- JUST CLOSE MY
REMARKS BUT IT'S A- I'D LIKE IT
NOTED ON THE RECORD THAT GOING
FORWARD WE MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
WHEN WE'RE DOING POLICY ON WHAT
WE'RE DOING BUDGET AND WHERE
THEY MATCH. THANK YOU. SO NOTED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR COMMENT- ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION BY SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR.
SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM FOR. A MEMBER. ARE I
CERTAINLY DEBATE ON IN BILL
STAND UP OR OBJECTS TO A BILL
HOWEVER I THINK IT IS A PRO TO
SET RECORDS STE ST A SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE. NUMBER ONE.
THE FEDERAL PAYROLL TAX CREDIT
AND YOU KNOW THAT IN MY OPENING
REMARKS I REFERRED TO A PAYROLL
TAX CREDIT THIS IS NOT JUST ANY
TAX CREDIT THIS IS A PAYROLL
TAX CREDIT AND THUS WHETHER YOU
GENERATE REVENUE OR NOT IF YOU
HAVE A PAYROLL YOU DO PAY
QUARTERLY PAYROLL TAXES AND SO
IT DOES ALLOW YOU TO TAKE A
CREDIT ON THOSE PAYROLL TAXES
AND IT IS WHY IT IS ALSO
APPLICABLE TO NON PROFITS
NONPROFITS DON'T GENERATE
REVENUE. SO IF IT WERE SOME
OTHER KIND OF TAX CREDIT THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
THIS HOWEVER THIS IS APPLICABLE
TO NONPROFITS SECONDARILY D.
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT DOES PROVIDE
FIVE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN PER
DAY. FOR LEAVE RELATED SELF
CARE IN OTHER WORDS IF THE
PERSON THEMSELVES HAS COVERED.
MUST BE QUARANTINE FOR COVERED.
OR HEAD NEEDS THE BACK TO POINT
WORSE REACTING TO THE VACCINE
SO ANY SELF CARE. PROVIDES THE
FIVE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN PER DAY
TAX CREDIT WHICH COVERS ALL
EMPLOYEES. SIXTY DOLLAR PAID
SIXTY BUCKS AN HOUR OR LOWER.
AND WILD YES THERE ARE SOME
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA RECEIVE
A HIGHER WAGE THAN SIXTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR. IT IS FEW. THE
PRIME THE MAJORITY OF EMPLOYEES
RECEIVED. SIXTY BUCKS OR LESS
FAR LESS AN HOUR- THE BILL ALSO
DOES NOT TRIGGER PACK A
VIOLATIONS EMPLOYEES WOULD HAVE
TO FILE FOR BACK WAGES IN WHICH
IN ORDER TO UP TO UTILIZE THIS
SAFER JANUARY OR FEBRUARYAND
IN WHICH CASE BUSINESSES AND
HAVE A CHANCE. TO PAY AND TO S.
THE SENATOR FROM NEW POINTED
OUT. THE WAGED. IN THE FULL
PERIOD FOR WHEN THE BILL
BECOMES EFFECTIVE. IT IS ONLY
INSTANCES WHERE BUSINESSES DO
NOT PAY WAGES RIGHTFULLY BOAT.
THAT THERE MIGHT BE SUBJECT TO
A PACKAGE POINT TO A DOES NOT
TRIGGER PACK VIOLATIONS-
ADDITIONALLY AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE FOOD SECTOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
BILL JUST PASSED LAST YEAR ALSO
APPLIED RETROACTIVELY AND IT
DID NOT RESULT IN THE PROBLEMS
THAT WERE CITED. ON THIS FLOOR.
SO WITH THAT I HOPE THAT YOU
REALIZE THAT THIS IS. A VERY
SOUND POLICY AND IF ANYTHING
ONE COULD INDICATE THAT GIVEN
IF WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC WHICH
WILL ONLY BE CONTAINED IF WE
CAN CONTAIN THE SPREAD. AND THE
ABSOLUTELY BEST WAY TO CONTAIN
THE SPREAD BEYOND THE FACT OF
WEARING MASKS AS WE ARE.
KEEPING OUR DISTANCE IS TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CODED. OR WHO ARE ASYMPTOMATIC
WITH CODE ARE NOT GOING TO WORK
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO WORK
SPREADS THE DISEASE SO IT IS IN.
IT IS FOR US TO GET THIS PAN
CONTAIN. SO THAT ARE GOINGTO
BE FULLY RE. AND WE CAN RETURN
TORN BUSINESS BUT UNTIL WE DO
SO. WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO.
FUNCTION AS WE HAVE IN THE PAST
SO ENSURING THAT WORKERS DO NOT
GO TO WORK. WHEN THEY ARE SICK
AND CAN SPREAD COBIT IT'S
IMPORTANT SO IF ANYTHING WE
HOPE THAT EMPLOYERS. UP TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES OR LESS. WOULD
BE WILLING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS WHILE THE BILL DOES NOT
MANDATED WE HOPE THAT THEY WILL
BECAUSE WE HOPE THAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES ALSO DO NOT GO TO
WORK WHEN THEY COULD SPREAD
COPAYS. AND WITH THAT I ASK
YOUR ABOUT. SENATORS WE WILL GO
THROUGH THE ROLL CALL ONE TIME
AND PLACE THE MEASURES ON CALL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO BAKER. I FORGES NO
BRADFORD. I HAVE I GOT. I
PROCESS HE I DALLY NO DODD HI
DERISIVE FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO HURTS. HI
HUESO. I HER TADO HI JONES NO
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA.
MCGUIRE I MILLION FIVE NEWMAN.
I NIELSEN. NO A JOB. NO HAN
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE. I'M HI
MIKE HOW HI WIENER I WILL. NO
THIS MATTER WE'RE GOING TO PAY
ON CALL SO MOVE ON TO MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOTHING UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
YES SENATOR OTOBO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
HAVE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE. GO AHEAD SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING OUT OF PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS ARE PROTEIN
RECOGNIZED ON MONDAY BUT
TODAY'S THE ACTUAL BIRTHDAY FOR
THE SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD
AND FROM ALL ARE YOUR
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF WE WISH
YOU A VERY VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT AND-
THERE WILL BE A PARTY IN HER
OFFICE RIGHT AFTER I GUESS.
JUST KIDDING UNDER COVERT WILL
HAVE TO WAIT ON THAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'M WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
FILE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWENTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS THIRTY FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY FOUR.SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS FIVE
FORTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS. AND
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. WE
COULD JUST TAKE A MINUTE.
ARMORED SENATOR HERTZBERG UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE. HEY I'M COMING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
RELATES TO THE- WHAT THE
CONFIRMATION OF JOSEPH WILLIAMS
TO THE APPOINTMENT OF FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS WE INTERVIEWED HIM AT
RULES COMMITTEE MY FORMER
POSITION HE WAS QUITE
IMPRESSIVE HE SERVES ON THE
SAMBAR TO DINO COMMITTEE
COLLEGE BOARD OF TRUSTEES. AND
IS THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS MANAGER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON HOW
ARE RULES COMMITTEE APPROVED
HIM ON MARCH TENTH A FIVE TO
ZERO VOTE UNANIMOUS VOTE ASK
YOUR SUPPORT WAS CONFIRMATION.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS APPOINTMENT. SAYING
THEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
FIVE EIGHT. I BAKER. FIVE
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD BYE BYE ADAM FIVE
COURTESY I DOUBT. I DODD BY THE
RISING I EGGMAN. EGGMAN. FIVE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS. I
HERTZBERG HI HUESO I HER TADO
HI JOE. FIVE KAMLAGER FIVE
LAYERED I LEYVA. MCGUIRE I MAN
FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN. HI
ATTILA BOTH I CAN I PORTANTINO
I ROTH FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER I
STERN I'M- HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER. I WILL HI. THIS ITEM
WILL BE ON. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SENATOR
HEARD. THANK YOU UP. VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT RELATES TO
CONFIRMATION OF APPOINTEES TO
THE STATE PARKS AND RECREATION
COMMISSION- FIRST IS A SERRA
BARTH SIR BARTH I A GRADUATE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN
YOU MISTER PENNSYLVANIA WITH X.
BUT WITH HER DEGREES IN-
ENVIRONMENT AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AND BIOLOGICAL BASIS
OF BEHAVIOR THE SECOND IS OUR
SMALL MOHADI HE IS ALL HE US
MOHADI IS. A GRADUATE OF. THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA LOS ANGELES BOTH AGAIN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCES AND
CATHERINE TOY CATHERINE TOYS
FROM THE LEGAL STANFORD JUNIOR
UNIVERSITY. WITH SIMILAR TYPES
OF BACKGROUND ALL IMPRESSIVE
APPOINTEES ALL OF WHOM ARE
DESERVE YOUR SUPPORT CAME OUT
OF. RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
TENTH FOR TWO FOUR YESES ONE
OBSESSION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BOTH OF THESE
CONFIRMATIONS. SENATOR GLAZERS.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS PART IS
A RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT IF
YOU LOOK AT HER CREDENTIALS THE
BREATH AND SERVICE TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR EXTRAORDINARY
LITERATURE CONFIRMATION TODAY
AS WELL AS THE OTHER- NOMINEES
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD. HI CABALLERO HI
COURTESY HI DALLY. DODD HI
DERISIVE HI EGGMAN I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED
I LEYVA. MCGUIRE FIVE MILLION I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. BUT CHAO OF
BOTH. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN.
NUMBER HI HI WHITE HOUSE HE I
WIENER I WILL. NOW CENTERS THIS
WILL BE PLACED ON CALL AS WELL
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO
SENATE THIRD READING ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN ACTION. ACTUALLY
WE WILL. PASS THAT TEMPORARILY
AND MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO CENTER GLACIER ARE
YOU PREPARED. HE IS PLEASE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIXTY BY SENATOR
GLAZER AN ACTUAL LIVING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
GLAZERS THE FORAGERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS UP FOR
NEW MEMBERS YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THIS BILL IT PASSED THE
FLOOR OUT LAST YEAR BY A WIDE
MARGIN ALSO THE ASSEMBLY- WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE CLOCK RAN OUT
OF MONEY COMING BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE- FOR NEW MEMBERS
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A NEW TOOL TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WERE MODERATE FEES
MAY ENHANCE THE TOOL THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE. TO FIND OUT
PEOPLE WHO FRIEND OUT PARTY.
BAY IN NEIGHBORHOODS- WITH THE
A REAL. PURPOSE TO- I JUST AND-
AND MONEY. FIVE THESE THE SHORT
TERM RENTALS A ONE I'M FOR TO
WORDS AND MONEY AND TO HELP. WE
WANT TO GO ON VACATION THERE
ARE FEW USERS OUT THERE WE HAD
A BIG TRASH IN MY- FIVE PEOPLE
SHOT KILLED. AT A SHORT TERM
RENTAL PARTY HOUSE- A YEAR AGO
LAST HALLOWEEN SO THIS IS
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOL BASKET
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HOLD
FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE THAT- ABUSE
ARE SHORT TERM RENTAL WORK.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR BURGESS. THE
PRESIDENT- MAN POSES A QUESTION
TO THE AUTHOR IF HILL. HAVE IT
ON. SATURDAY WOULD YOU TAKE THE
QUESTION YEAH HE WILL. SO I
KNOW THE ARE NONE A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES- THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN WANTING
TO SUPPORT THE HOTEL INDUSTRY-
BY HAVING MORE RESTRICTIVE
MEASURES. FOR THOSE- THAT ARE
IN THE AIRBNB CONTEXT. HAS
THERE BEEN ANY. ESTIMATE ON
WHAT THIS WOULD DO TO THE LOCAL
ECONOMIES THAT THRIVE THROUGH
THE SAID SHORT TERM INFORMAL OF
RENTALS. THE CHAIR THIS BILL
DOESN'T CHANGE ANY EXISTING
RULES AND REGULATIONS THAT
COUNTIES AND CITIES CAN USE TO
LIVE IN FORCE THEIR CODES IN
REGARD TO SHORT TERM RENTALS SO
THERE'S A WHOLE VARIETY OF-
ACTIONS AND REACTIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN AROUND THE STATE ON
THESE MATTERS- THIS BILL
DOESN'T INTERFERE WITH ANY OF
THOSE CHOICES DOESN'T LIMIT
THEM DOESN'T EXPAND THEM. IT
SIMPLY SAYS THAT IF YOU HAVE
EIGHT A AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
CONTINUES TO RENT OUT A HOUSE
FOR ILLEGAL PARTIES THAT ON THE
SECOND- COMPLAINT BEING FILED
AND ON THE THIRD THAT THE FINAL
LEVELS CAN GO UP. THE SHORT
TERM RENTAL HOUSES FOR PARTIES
CAN WE GO OUT FOR TWO THOUSAND
A DAY FIVE THOUSAND A DAY TEN
THOUSAND A DAY AN EXISTING FINE
STRUCTURE THAT'S A THOUSAND OR
BELOW IT'S JUST NOT A
DISINCENTIVE THAT'S ALL THIS
BILL DOES IN THAT NARROW SPACE
IT'S ADD THE TOOLS DOESN'T
CHANGE ANY OF THOSE REGULATORY.
ISSUES IN WHICH YOU RATES.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
CENTER GLAZER YOU MAY CONCLUDE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU SO MUCH. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BECKER. HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD. HI BYRON HI COURTESY
I DALLY. I DODD HI DERISIVE I
EGGMAN. HI PLEASE. HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH NO. I HUESO. FIVE FOR
TODD. I JONES NO CAMERA. I
LAYERED I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE
FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
BY A SHOW OF BOTH. I PAN I
PORTANTINO HI ROTH. FIVE RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER I WHITE
HOUSE HE. NO WE- FIVE WILK NOW.
THAT MEASURE WILL BE PLACED ON
pITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AND MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE I
SEE THAT SENATOR MAN IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION TWELVE BY
MEN RELATIVE TO HATE CRIMES
CENTERMAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES NUMBERS TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SACRAMENTO. I PERCENT
SENATE RESOLUTION TWELVE WHICH
CAN DAMAGE THE IMPORTANT HATE
CRIMES AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS
AND ASKS THIS BODY TO ENSURE
THAT API'S FEEL SAFE AND
WELCOME IN THE STATE. TWO
NIGHTS AGO WE SAW YET ANOTHER
INCIDENT OF HATE AGAINST API
SAYS EIGHT PEOPLE WERE KILLED
IN THE LATEST INCIDENTS OF GUN
VIOLENCE THIS ONE TARGETED
ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN. I LEARNED
ABOUT THIS MASSACRE AS I WAS IN
THE MIDDLE OF PRESENTING A GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION BILL BEFORE
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
HOURS AFTER I PRESENTED THIS
RESOLUTION S. R. TWELVE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. NOW HE'S-
A CLEAR THAT ENTIRE EIGHTY I
HATE IS NOT NEW TO AMERICA OR
EVEN CALIFORNIA BUT GOES BACK
TO THE HISTORY OF ASIAN
IMMIGRATION. LONG AGO ASIAN
AMERICANS WERE SUBJECTED TO THE
YELLOW PERIL RHETORIC OF THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY. ACCOMPANIED
BY A WIDE ARRAY OF HATEFUL AND
VIOLENT ACTS. API'S WERE
SUBJECTED TO GROSSLY
DISCRIMINATORY LAWS AT THE
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS.
FOR OVER A CENTURY AFTER THE
FOURTEENTH AND FIFTEENTH
AMENDMENTS TO THE CONSTITUTION
OR ADAPTED EXTENSIVELY
PROTECTING THE EQUAL RIGHTS OF
ALL THOSE BORN IN THIS COUNTRY.
ASIAN AMERICANS WERE RESTRICTED
FROM IMMIGRATING TO THIS
COUNTRY. AND THOSE ALREADY HERE
UNABLE TO COME CITIZENS VOTE
SERVE ON JURIES OR MANY STATES
EVEN PURCHASE PROPERTIES. JUST
A FEW WEEKS AGO WE MARK THE
SEVENTY NINE AND- OF PRESIDENT
ROOSEVELT'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
NINE OH SIX SIX. WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE INTERNMENT OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS THIS WAS ONE
OF THE MOST SHAMEFUL ACTIONS OF
THE ROOSEVELT ADMINISTRATION IN
THE STATE ON OUR COUNTRY'S
HISTORY. AND IT WAS NOT UNTIL
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
RESTRICTIONS ON ASIAN
IMMIGRATION WERE LIFTED. MY
PARENTS WERE PART OF THAT POST
SIXTY FIVE WAVE OF ASIAN
IMMIGRATION THAT BROUGHT SO
MANY ASIAN AMERICANS TO THIS
COUNTRY. AND TODAY WE'RE AT A
POINT WHERE ASIAN AMERICANS IN
MANY WAYS SEEMINGLY HAVE
ACHIEVED SUCCESS. API'S ARE
LEADERS IN BUSINESS LABOR
FINANCE ENTERTAINMENT
TECHNOLOGY ACADEMIA POLITICS.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLE MOMENT FOR
A COMMUNITY WHEN CONNELLY
HARRIS BECAME THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO THE WHITE
HOUSE. AND ASIAN MOVIE PARASITE
WON BEST PICTURE LAST YEAR AND
AN AMERICAN MOVIE ABOUT ASIAN.
IMMIGRANT FAMILY. WAS NOMINATED
FOR SIX OSCARS THIS YEAR
INCLUDING BEST PICTURE. BUT THE
STATE THE OBVIOUS FOR ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
NOW IS A TIME OF INCREDIBLE
UNCERTAINTY AND FEAR. AND THAT
IS WHY THIS RESOLUTION IS SO
IMPORTANT. IN RECENT YEARS
WE'VE SEEN THE PAST PRESENT
UNITED STATES DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST MUSLIM AMERICANS WITH
THE TRAVEL BAN THEY CAN'T
FAMILIES APART. THREATEN TO
REVOKE THE BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP THAT GUARANTEE SO
MANY API'S ARE BASIC RIGHTS IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND SCAPEGOAT
ASIAN AMERICANS AS THE COST OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RHETORIC
BLAMING CHINESE AMERICANS FOR
THE CROWN OF OURS HAS COINCIDED
WITH AN ALARMING SURGE IN ANTI
API HATE CRIMES. ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY WE'VE SEEN VIOLENT
ATTACKS AND OTHER OUTRAGEOUS
INCIDENTS OF RACISM DIRECTED
AGAINST API'S INCLUDING MANY
HERE IN THIS STATE. WE SAW THAT
MAN VISA RODHAM BUT OF POVERTY-
THE TIME IN EIGHTY FOUR YEARS
OLD PUSH TUESDAY WILL WALK.
INSTANCES THREE ELDERLY. NECK
DAY OR IN OAKLAND SKY THIS. I
JUST YES AND CHIU WOMAN WAS
ASSAULT IN SAN FRANCISCO. IN MY
HOME AREA ORANGE COUNTY MAY
HAVE SEEN WILL BE THAT API WE
BEING SO AT. CALLED THE CHINA
VIRUS AND BEING TOLD TO GO BACK
TO THEIR COUNTRIES. YOU MAY
HAVE READ ABOUT THE C. FAMILY
WHICH HAS BEEN HARASSED EVERY
NIGHT FOR FIVE MONTHS AT THEIR
NEW HOME IN LADERA RANCH. WITH
RACIALLY TARGETED INCIDENTS.
AND OF COURSE TWO NIGHTS AGO WE
SAW. SIX ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN
MURDERED BY MEN WHO BLAME THEM
FOR HIS OWN DEFICIENCIES. THIS
IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND IT IS. NOT AN
UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THIS IS
AN EPIDEMIC OF HATE. NEARLY ONE
IN THREE ASIAN AMERICANS REPORT
HAVING BEEN SUBJECTED TO
DISCRIMINATION SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC. AND
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT
RELEASED YESTERDAY OR TWO DAYS
AGO FROM STOP áP I HATE.
NEARLY THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED
HATE INCIDENTS HAVE BEEN
REPORTED AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS SINCE THE START OF
PANDEMIC. API'S ARE BEING
ACCOSTED HER RASCOFF ON SPEED
ON. A SALTY AND YES MURDERED.
WE ARE. WE'RE SCARED OR ANGRY
AND MANY API DO NOT FEEL
WELCOME IN THIS COUNTRY WE CALL
HOME. AND FRANKLY WE'RE TIRED
OF BEING ALONE IN THIS FIGHT
WE'RE TIRED OF BEING THE
INVISIBLE MINORITY WE WANT TO
BE SEEN AND HEARD AND VALIDATED
AND WE NEED YOUR VOICES THE
VOICES THE STATE LEGISLATURE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO STAND
WITH US LOUDLY AND FIRMLY AND
TELL US. AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
YOU ARE WELCOME AND CHERISHED
YEAR AND WE HAVE YOUR BACK
BECAUSE OF ASIAN AMERICANS DO
NOT FEEL WELCOME HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CONTINENTAL
STATE WITH THE HIGHEST NUMBER
INVITES FOR SENATE OF API'S
THEN WE'RE WE HE WELCOME. NO I
WANNA REMARK ON THE ROOF. OF IT
WENT TO EVERY LAWN FOR. TO THE-
TO DAYS AGO- BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S SOME. AND KRISTA. THE
FEELING THAT MANY YEARS
AMERICANS- YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
THE LONG. DESCRIBE THIS AS A
BAD DAY- AND DISMAY ANY RACIAL
MOTIVE DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE SHOOTER WAS CLEARLY
TARGETING API WOMEN. THIS
RHETORIC FOCUSED ON THE BADLY
THE SHOOTER AND IGNORING THE
LIVES OF THE VICTIMS DEMEANS US
NOR IS US AND IF THE VICTIMS
THE FAMILIES THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE DEVASTATED. AND WE'RE
TIRED OF BEING INVISIBLE. OUR
LIVES HAVE WORTH AND MEANING
AND VALUE AND WE WANT THAT TO
BE RECOGNIZED BY OUR SOCIETY. I
WANT TO BE CLEARED API
COMMUNITIES NOT THE ONLY
COMMUNITY THAT'S EXPERIENCED
RACISM AND HATE IN RECENT
YEARS. THE ALARMING RISE OF
WHITE NATIONALISM HAS COINCIDED
WITH AN INCREASE IN HATE DRIVEN
ATTACKS ON A NUMBER OF
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. WE'VE
SEEN MUSLIMS JEWS LGBTQ AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS AND MANY
OTHERS TARGETED. AND SO I WANT
TO SAY I'M DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE SUPPORT OF THE API
COMMUNITY BY THE LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
SUPPORT MATTERS BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IF WE COME TOGETHER WE
OUTNUMBER THEM BY A LOT. THERE
ARE SO MANY MORE OF US WHO
BELIEVE IN OUR CORE VALUES OF
LOVE. UNITY AND DIVERSITY
INCLUSIVITY. MORE THE BOSTON
THOSE WHO BELIEVE IN HATE AND
DIVISION AND RACISM AND I
BELIEVE WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
AND VOICE OUR SUPPORT WILL
DROWN OUT THE VOICES OF THE
RACISTS AND HATERS. BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT ASIAN AMERICANS
ARE NOT HEARING THOSE VOICES
RIGHT NOW. WE FEEL ALONE WE
FEEL MARGINALIZED WE FEEL
INVISIBLE AND SO S. R. TWELVE
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
RECTIFYING THAT WE NEED TO PASS
THIS TODAY TO MAKE SURE THAT
ARE ASIANS YOUR ASIAN AMERICAN
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
YOUR FRIENDS AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES FEEL LIKE WE HAVE
DELEGATION AND WORTH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
OF. SENATOR- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IN AND THANK TO
COLLEAGUE FROM- OF FOR FORTH IS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. EARLIER
IN MY CAREER. IN A DIFFERENT
COLOR HAIR I PROSECUTED HE
CRIMES. THAT WAS BEFORE WE KNEW
MUCH ABOUT THE GROUPS THAT
PERPETRATED THEM. IT'S AN
INTERESTING SET OF INDIVIDUALS.
WHO COMMIT THESE CRIMES THEY'RE
NOT CRIMES MOTIVATED BY AVARICE
OR PASSION. THEY'RE MOTIVATED
BY THE DESIRE TO SEND A MESSAGE
TO SEND A MESSAGE TO A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS. THE TERRORIZE THEM.
IT ASO SENDS A MESSAGE TO
THEIR FELLOW TRAVELERS THAT
THAT. THEY HAVE THE GUTS TO ACT
ON WHAT THEY THINK OTHERS THINK.
AND THEY LOOK FOR SUBTLE IN
IMPERCEPTIBLE MESSAGES
DELIVERED BY. THOSE IN
AUTHORITY. BECAUSE THEY THINK
THOSE SUBTLE IMPERCEPTIBLE
MESSAGES. ARE WHAT OTHERS
BELIEVE. HARD PRESSED
UNDERSTAND I THINK SO WHEN
SOMEONE SAYS THAT ENTIRE GROUP
OF PEOPLE ARE RAPISTS AND
MURDERERS. THEY THINK THAT
OTHERS AGREE SO WHEN SOMEONE
SAYS THAT. THEY THINK THAT
THERE ARE VERY FINE PEOPLE WHO
CHANT. THE JEWS WILL NOT
REPLACE US. THEY THINK THEY'RE
FELLOW TRAVELERS SO THEY THINK
WHEN SOMEONE IDENTIFIES A
HORRIBLE DISEASE AS THE CHINA
VIRUS THEY THINK THAT SOMEONE
AGREES WITH THEM. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SPEAK WITH
ONE VOICE TO SAY WE DON'T AGREE.
WE DON'T AGREE MARTIN FOR US TO
SPEAK WITH ONE VOICE NOT THE
COUNTENANCE THAT KIND OF
MESSAGE SUBTLE AS IMPERCEPTIBLE
AS SOME MAY THINK IT IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS A GROWING THREAT
TO INVESTIGATE TO GATHER
INTELLIGENCE TO ANALYZE AND
OPERATIONALIZE SO THAT WE CAN
MEET THIS THREAT. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION HIGHER G.
UNANIMOUS VOTE THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT ARRIVES TODAY AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE API
COMMUNITY HIGH AUTHORIZES THE
SENATOR WHO REPRESENTS NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF API OUR COMMUNITY- THE
HORRIFIC MURDERS OF EIGHT
PEOPLE AND AT LATIMES EARLIER
THIS WEEK- ARE ONCE AGAIN A
REMINDER OF THE RISE IN ANTI
ASIAN HE CRIMES VIOLENT HATE
CRIMES ACROSS THE COUNTRY. FIND
DETAILS EARLIER THIS WEEK- A
MEMBER OF THE FILIPINO
COMMUNITY WAS VIOLENTLY
ASSAULTED IN DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE HAVE HAD A
SERIES OF ATTACKS PARTICULARLY
ON API ELDERS- IN SAN FRANCISCO
IN DALY CITY AND I KNOW AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE AS
WELL THIS IS NOT JUST A
COINCIDENCE THIS IS A PATTERN
FIVE AND A HALF TO STOP. AS
CHIU WE KNOW ALL WELL THE
IMPACT OF THE BIGOTRY GO ON.
THE MURDERS IN GEORGIA ARE YET
IN EXAMPLE. OF HOW HARM WHY.
HATEFUL LANGUAGE TURNS INTO THE-
VIOLENCE THE TWO OUR CONNECT.
AND WE YEARS WE HAVE SEEN. IT
FROM RISE IN HE VIOLENCE
TARGETING THE API COMMUNITY
JEWS MUSLIMS LGBTQ PEOPLE AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. BUT
THIS TREND HAS INCREASED AT A
MUCH MORE RAPID PACE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IN FACT THIS WEEK THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE RELEASED
A REPORT THAT WHITE SUPREMACIST
PROPAGANDA DOUBLED IN TWENTY
TWENTY PERMITS ALREADY
HISTORICALLY. HIGH LEVELS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. WHAT SUPREMACY
HIT INCIDENTS. ANY COMMUNITY
HARMS ALL OF US AND WE CANNOT
BECOME NUMB. TO THIS VIOLENCE
THIS HATE AND WE MUST BE
ESPECIALLY WARY OF HELL COOPER
HAS BEEN WEAPONIZED AGAINST C.
API COMMUNITY AND TO DEADLY OX.
JUST THIS WEEK OUR FORMER
PRESIDENT ONCE AGAIN WENT ON TV
AND REFERRED TO COVER NINETEEN
AS THE QUOTE. CHINESE VIRUS.
THE JEWISH PART PRAY TO BE WORK
WITH THE API. ONE HATE CRIME
AND BUDGET REQUESTS TO ENSURE
THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF
OUR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
AGAIN WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE API COMMUNITY ENTERS
AN IDLE. SENATOR PENN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS
SIGN HI TO RISE AND THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM IRVINE- FOR
INTRODUCING SR TWELVE IN THE
SPHERE OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS-
AGAIN WANT TO THANK- MADE USE
HERE WHO'S MADE EXPRESSIONS OF
SOLIDARITY WITH THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY. AND
I WON'T REITERATE- WHAT IS
ALREADY BEEN SAID IN TERMS OF-
THE RECENT INCIDENTS- THE FACT
THAT- ON THE SAME DAY WE HAD A
REPORT THAT SHOWED THAT. THERE
RISING- SO MANY THOUSANDS OF
INCIDENTS OF HATE AGAINST- AGI
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- TUBES.
THAT TWICE AS MANY WERE AGAINST
A WHEN. INTERSECTS WITH THE
RACISM INVOLVED AND- FOR API
WOMEN TO BE OBJECTIFIED- ED AND
HYPER SEXUALIZED IS- SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AS WELL
SO MANY. ISSUE ALSO FOR- WOMEN
OF OTHER OF COLOR AND OTHER
RACES AS WELL BUTI DON'T WANT
TO TAKE THE FOCUS MY REMARKS ON
WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE- MANY OF YOU AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED IT SAID WELL
I WANT TO HELP WHAT CAN I DO.
AND SO FIRST OF ALL I ASK THAT
WE ELEVATE- IS A PACIFIC
ISLANDER VOICES AND STORIES I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- THIS IS
NOW OVER TWENTY FOUR HOURS
SINCE THE- AGAIN THE MURDER. OF
EIGHT PEOPLE SIX API WOMEN YET
WE KNOW MUCH MORE ABOUT THE
MURDERER THAN WE KNOW ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE MURDERED- DO WE
KNOW THAT. THEY HAVE CHILDREN
DID WE KNOW THAT THEY- HAVE-
WHAT THEIR LIFE STORY WAS. OUR
THE PEOPLE TO US YET. I'M NOT
SURE. WE DON'T- AND SO WE NEED
TO WE NEED TO WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THESE ARE HUMAN BEINGS
AS WELL. WHO HAVE STORIES. AND
RELATIONSHIPS. AND SO WE NEED
TO BE SURE WE ELEVATE API
VOICES AND STORIES. SO PLEASE
HELP ELEVATE MEMBERS ARE
COMMUNITIES TELL THEIR STORIES.
WHEN WE SEE INCIDENTS OR
WITNESSED THEM OR- AND OF
COURSE WE AS LEADERS CAN
ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO DO THE SAME
TO INTERVENE IN THE ESCALATE.
SO WHEN SOMEONE ENGAGES AND
RACIST REMARKS DON'T BE SILENT
STAND WITH US SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT IT THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
IN ADDITION WE NEED TO CALL ON
COMPANIES AND ORGANIZATIONS TO
NOT PLATFORM. HE AND INCIDENTS
OF VIOLENCE. WHEN DATE PLATFORM
THEM TO GIVE SOMEONE A
MEGAPHONE FOR THIS THEN THEY
ARE ALSO ENCOURAGING IT. SO WE
NEED TO CALL ON. OUR TO OUR
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES OUR OUR
MEDIA COMPANY ON MEDIA OTHER
TYPES OF PEOPLE WHO. ARE IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO REDUCE THE-
PLATFORM NOT THE PLATFORM
EIGHT. WE ALSO NEED TO SUPPORT
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER- NOT FOR
PROFITS AND BUSINESSES I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT PRIOR TO COPE
WITH AS COLEMAN WAS COMING EVEN
BEFORE. ANY OF THE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS THAT ACTUALLY API
BUSINESSES ARRAY SAW DRAMATIC
DROPS IN- REVENUE BECAUSE OF
DISCRIMINATION AND PREJUDICE
AGAINST THEM. AND OFTEN TIME
EIGHTY AYE NOT FROM NOT FOR
PROFITS ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THE ISSUES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. ARE SOMETIMES
LEAST FUNDED- FROM PHILANTHROPY
OR FROM OTHER- PEOPLE AS WELL
SO WE NEED TO SUPPORT NOT FOR
PROFIT BUSINESSES AND ELEVATE
THEM. WE ALSO NEED TO SUPPORT
POLICIES THAT GIVE A CALL
ACCESS TO SERVICES TO EVERYONE
INCLUDING API. AND THAT MEANS
LANGUAGE ACCESS WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET AN
INTERPRETER SERVICES FOR PEOPLE-ON MEDICARE FOR YEARS NOW I
THINK OUR PRETEND FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN THAT. BUT THAT
KEEPS DRAGGING ON WE NEED TO
HAVE EQUAL LANGUAGE ACCESS TO
ALL OUR SERVICES. AND I WOULD
pCOMMITTEE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE ACTION MAJORITY
IMMIGRANTS. SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
THAT AFFECTS THE API COMMUNITY.
SO WHEN WE DONE THE NINE
SERVICES TO IMMIGRANTS THAT.
THAT HAD TO OUTSIZE IMPACT ON
THE COMMUNITY. SO THESE ARE
JUST A FEW OF THE THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO TOGETHER- AS LEADERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY REALLY WANTED
AGAIN THANK OF PEOPLE INCLUDING
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WHO HAS
COME TO ME AND SAID WE WANT TO
STAND WITH THE API COMMUNITY
WILL SUPPORT. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- SO BUT WE NEED
YOU MORE THAN EVER NOW. YEAH
COMMITTEE NEEDS ALL OF YOU.
MORE THAN EVER AND SO WITH THAT
I URGE- I VOTE ON S. R. TWELVE
AND AGAIN I WANT TO THANK. ALL
OF YOU WHO HAVE SAID THAT YOU
WANT TO HELP. OUR COMMUNITY-
TRY TO. GET BASICALLY. BE HEARD.
pTHAT WE- ARE CONSIDERED AN
EQUAL PART. OF THE AMERICAN
FABRICS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE THANK YOU. SENATOR
MURKOWSKI THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SANDERS YEAH I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
PAUSE YOU KNOW WE SERVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE AND WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF REASONS THAT
WE COME HERE AND WE WORK ON
BILLS SO WE GET CREDIT AND
RECOGNITION FOR THAT AND WE
HAVE. DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
RESOLUTIONS SOMETIMES WE DO
HAVE JOINTLY WITH THE ASSEMBLY
WE WANT LIKE TO TELL THE
CONGRESS WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
WE SHOULD DO SOME INTERNATIONAL
BODY OR RECOGNIZE SOME SPECIAL
PROFESSION OR- SOME DISEASE
THAT THEY HAPPEN THESE
DIFFERENT. WEEKS BUT FROM TIME
TO TIME. THE SENATE. STANDS UP
AND MAKES A POINT OF WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE IN IN THE
WORLD. AND THAT'S WHAT SENATE
RESOLUTION. IS DOING RIGHT NOW
NUMBER TWELVE IS DOING ITS
RECOGNIZING. FOR AT THIS MOMENT
IN TIME THESE APPALLING THIS
APPALLING INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES. MY COLLEAGUES TO TALK
SO ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE NUMBERS
ABOUT THESE HATEFUL. OF THE
HATEFUL RHETORIC THAT'S GOING
AROUND. IN THE END THAT HATEFUL
ACTS AGAINST OUR ASIAN PACIFIC
ASIAN AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS IT'S THIS BODY WE
THIS CALIFORNIA SENATE. BY OUR
VOTE EMPIRE ACTIONS BUT NOW THE
SIX IT'S SO SIMPLE SOMETIMES
BUT IT'S ALSO POIGNANT BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE ADDS THEIR VOICE THROUGH
THIS YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
FIRM. UP ORANGE COUNTY TALKED
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE HATE CRIME
THE PERSON WHO COMMITS A CRIME
THEY WANT TO SEND THE MESSAGE
THEY WANTED BIG BIG BIG THANK
THEIR ACTION IS WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE ARE THINKING. WILL BE.
BY GOD THIS IS SOMETHING THE
CALIPHATE EVERY THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE IS GOING TO DO THAT WE
WANT TO SEND AN ACTION WE WANT
TO SEND A RESPONSE. THAT WE THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE. AGREED TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS OUR CITIZENS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT ALL APRA'S
FEEL SAFER. AND MORE WELCOME IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND AYE
RIGID AYE VOTE. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMERS BY RICE IS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN ALLIANCE WITH
THE API CAUCUS AND ALL OF OUR
OTHER CARCASSES AND HOPEFULLY
ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES TODAY ON
THE FLOOR TO SUPPORT S. R.
TWELVE BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
COSTA MESA. AS MANY HAVE
INDICATED SO FAR IN THEIR
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS FLOOR
TODAY. WE DENOUNCE AND THIS
RESOLUTION DENOUNCES HATE
CRIMES HATEFUL RHETORIC AND
HATEFUL ACTS AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
WHICH ARE GROWING IN NUMBER
ACROSS THE STATE AND NATION.
AND WHILE HATE CRIMES HAVE BEEN
PRESENT. FOR DECADES IN THIS
COUNTRY THE SPECIFIC A TAX ON
OUR API COMMUNITY HAVE
INCREASED GREATLY IN THE LAST
YEAR. AND OF COURSE THE MASS
SHOOTING THAT OCCURRED THIS
WEEK IN ATLANTA APPEARS TO
TARGET API WOMEN SPECIFICALLY.
AND ACCORDING TO THE STOCK AP I
HATE HATE CRIME HOTLINE. WOMEN
REPORTED HATE INCIDENTS TWO
POINT THREE TIMES MORE OFTEN
THAN MEN. WHICH AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
POINTED OUT IS AN ELEMENT OF
MISOGYNY AS WELL. I'M VERY
PROUD THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
CONTINUED TO TAKE ACTION TO
COMBAT RACISM AND HATE CRIMES
IN ALL FORMS. IN ORDER TO NOW
IT'S MADE OF THESE HORRIFIC
ACTS WE HOPE. THAT AS AMERICANS
WE CAN COME TOGETHER AND HONOR
AND RESPECT ALL PEOPLE
INDEPENDENT OF THEIR ETHNICITY
THEIR GENDER OR ANY OTHER
CHARACTERISTIC THAT RATHER WE
RESPECT IN ORDER. AARON'S
BACKED INTO LOVE TOWARDS OUR
COMMON HUMANITY WHICH- WHAT PUT
INTO PRACTICE THE IN GOD WE
TRUST WHICH IS INVOKED
CONTINUALLY WITHIN OUR COUNTRY.
SO WITH THAT SO I ASK THAT WE
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PUT AN
END TO HAITI ACCESS CAN I ASK
FOR. YOUR AYE VOTE FOR S. R.
TWELVE THANK YOU. SENATOR CHAU
BOTH. MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
OF ISIS SUPPORTERS ARE TWELVE.
MEMBERS OF OUR EIGHTY API
COMMUNITY HAVE BEEN FACING A
RICE AND SENSELESS AND VIOLENT
HATE CRIMES IT TAX THAT WE HAVE
SEEN PERPETRATED AGAINST OUR
API BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN
THIS COUNTRY ARE ON AMERICAN AN
UNACCEPTABLE. IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE NOT ONLY CONDEMNED THE
STATE BUT ALSO TAKE ACTUAL
STEPS TO ADDRESS IT AND ROOT IT
OUT. WHICH IS WHY I WAS AFFRONT
TO SUPPORT AB EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
PROVIDES NECESSARY AID FOR
ADDRESSING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
OUR WORK DOES NOT END HERE. WE
MUST CONTINUE TO STANISLAUS AND
CELEBRATE SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
API BROTHERS AND SISTERS. AND
TYLER MEMBERS OF THE API
COMMITTEE. I STAND WITH YOU I
WILL CONTINUE TO USE MY VOICE
FOR YOU. SENATOR BE THE SENATE
OH I'M SORRY THAT'S- NUMBER.
TWO SENATOR FROM IRVINE. I
WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT WE HEAR
YOU. WE SEE YOU. WE WILL HELP
IN ANY WAY AND IT WOULD START
WITH US IT STARTS WITH ME. AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF MY AREA. I
CAN NOT ONLY WILL MODEL
ABSOLUTE RESPECT AND BE THERE
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. AB I
COMMUNITIES IN OUR AREA BUT
ONCE IN MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
HEAR YOU AND WE DO SEE. I WILL
WORK TOWARDS ELIMINATING ANY
BIGOTRY IN ANY HATE OF ANY FORM
FOR ANY GROUP AND IT STARTS
WITH ME AND MODELING WHAT WE
WANT TO SEE. AN OLD ONE HERE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT WORK. SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU A GOOD NEWS STORY AND
A ROLE MODEL COMMUNITY ON THIS
VERY ISSUE WHO REALLY
CONFRONTED THEY HATE AND RACISM
THAT WAS OCCURRING ON IN THEIR
COMMUNITY THE COMMUNITY OF
LADERA RANCH WHICH IS GOOD
SENATOR FROM IRVINE MANSION DOG
AND THE NUMBER OF INCIDENTS
THAT HAVE OCCURRED ROSE UP. TO
PROTECT THE FAMILY THAT WAS
BEING HARASSED CONTINUALLY THEY
SET UP A FIVE EIGHT BOB PROGRAM
WHERE THEY TOOK TURNS FROM
MIDNIGHT UNTIL FROM SIX O'CLOCK
UNTIL MIDNIGHT EVERY NIGHT TO
STAND GUARD AT THIS HOUSE SO
I'D LIKE YOU TO KNOW THAT WHEN
WE HAVE THESE INCIDENTS OUT
THERE THERE ARE ROLE MODELS AND
I AYE REYES LADERA RANCH. HOUSE
ONE OF THOSE OF THIS COMMUNITY
OF ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND NOW
RESIDENTS THEY ALL GATHER NOT
JUST ON THE PHONE SEVERAL
INCIDENCES THAT HAVE OCCURRED
IN THEIR COMMUNITY THERE'S
GOODNESS OUT THERE GUYS IT IS
AT WORK THERE ARE ROLE MODELS
AND WE JUST NEED TO OUR FEATURE
THEM- BECAUSE THEY BECOME THE
ROLE MODELS OF HOW YOU CAN
INDIVIDUALLY AND THEN
COLLECTIVELY AS THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SINCE SANTA ANA
MENTIONED TO US STAND UP
AGAINST WHAT WE SEE. ARE AND
HOLD IS A MINORITY OF THE
PEOPLE IN THIS NATION WHO STILL
HAVEN'T YOU KNOW BEEN EDUCATED
AND ARE ARE ABLE TO ELIMINATE
THE BIAS SEES THAT FROM HOW I
DEVELOPED AND THEIR FAMILIES I
SAY THAT BECAUSE THE THOSE WHO
WERE AT THE HEART OF THIS
HARASSMENT IN LADERA RANCH WERE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE IN
FACT UNDER THE AGE OF FIFTEEN.
SO WITHOUT- LET US KEEP IN OUR
HEARTS AND OUR MINDS THAT THERE
IS GOOD ENOUGH THERE ARE GOOD
ROLE MODELS AND THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT WE NEED TO FEATURE
WHEN WE TALK. ABOUT THESE
INCIDENTS THANK YOU. SENATOR
WRESTLE. THANK YOU BETTER
PRISON CENTERS ARE REALLY THIS
I THINK IS A REAL ONE
CONVERSATION I HAVE IT AT A
PRESENTS CALIFORNIAN AN OPEN
WAY I THINK WE NEED TO REALLY
PROMOTE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S
REPLACEMENT COLLUSION THE STATE
OF TOLERANCE TO STATE THAT
WELCOMES PEOPLE OF ALL.
BACKGROUNDS AND- CULTURES AND
RELIGIONS. YOU KNOW IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT TO MENTION AND PUT
THIS IN CONTEXT IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY IN THAT BECAUSE OF THIS
DISCOVERY OF GOLD CALIFORNIA
WAS ADMITTED AS A STATE WITHOUT
A COMPANION SLAVE STATE SO WAS
ADMITTED AS A FREE STATE WAS
BASICALLY THE STATE THAT
ULTIMATELY CONTRIBUTED TO. THE
FIGHT FOR THE EMANCIPATION OF
SLAVERY AND DURING THAT TIME
AND DURING THE CIVIL WAR IT WAS
THE NATIVE MEXICANS WHAT WERE
CALLED THE CALIFORNIANS THAT
WERE ACTUALLY THE BIGGEST
ADVOCATES FOR THE ENDING OF
SLAVERY AND THAT'S WHY SINGLE
TAMAYO STILL CELEBRATING
CALIFORNIA TODAY BECAUSE THAT
WAS REALLY A CELEBRATION OF THE
END OF SLAVERY AND THE END OF
THE POTENTIAL EXPANSION OF
SLAVERY FROM EUROPE INTO
MEXICO. AND THEN. FOLLOWING
THAT THERE WERE A LOT OF. VERY
SAD ACTIONS THAT ARE STATE
TOOK. TO ME IN THIS VERY FLOOR
THAT WERE SITTING ON TODAY THEY
ACTUALLY VOTED TO CREATE
BOUNTIES. ON NATIVE AMERICANS
LIVES. AND ATTACKS ON ASIANS.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO MINE FOR
GOLD IN THE STATE. SO THERE
THERE IS A DUBIOUS HISTORY AND
IN THE STATE'S PARTICIPATION IN
INTOLERANCE AND RACIST
ACTIVITIES THAT DIDN'T HELP THE
STATE BECOME. THE GREAT COMEDY
KANEMI IT IS TODAY AND I ARGUE
THAT CONFLICT. BIGOTRY HATRED
RACISM ARE A CANCER ON OUR
COUNTRY OUR STATE THAT REALLY.
AFFECT OUR ECONOMY AND JUST SO
MANY HORRIBLE WAYS AND IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IMPROVING OUR
ECONOMY AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS HERE. ABOUT
SUPPORTING BUSINESS AND MAKING
IT EASY TO OPERATE A BUSINESS
AND TO HAVE PEOPLE PROSPER IN
OUR STATE ONE OF THE CREW.
BIGGEST DETRIMENTS TO BUSINESS
ON OUR STATE IS HATRED BIGOTRY
AND THE TARGETING OF CERTAIN
BUSINESS OWNERS BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN OR THE
BACKGROUND. WE'VE SEEN IN OUR
VERY STATE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO CERTAIN BUSINESSES BE PUT
OUT BUSINESSES PUT OUT OF
BUSINESS AND BE TARGETED AND
SUFFER DAMAGE AND THEFT AND
CRIME. SIMPLY BECAUSE OF WHO
THE BUSINESS OWNER WHAT'S- AND
WE HAVE TO STOP THAT IF YOU
REALLY TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU
KNOW WHEN WE HEAR THINGS LIKE
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN. THAT
MAY MEAN DIFFERENT THINGS TO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND WE NEED TO
PUT A MEANING ON THAT THAT
REALLY MEANS. A HELP IN THE
PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY TO THRIVE
AND TO PROSPER AND TO BE ABLE
TO START THE BUSINESS HERE. AND
NOT WORRY ABOUT FACING IN.
CRIME AND- ACTIONS AGAINST HIM
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN REALLY WHAT HELP
MAKES CALIFORNIA GREAT IS THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE WE ARE
THE MOST DIVERSE STATE IN THE
COUNTRY THAT'S WHY WE'RE THE
LARGEST ECONOMY THAT'S WHY
WE'RE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD. BECAUSE OF THE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE BACKGROUNDS
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR STATE
CONTRIBUTING TO THIS AMERICAN
DREAM INTO THE- MATRIX OF. OF
THE VARIOUS THREADS THAT WEAVE
THIS AMAZING TAPESTRY THAT IS
CALIFORNIA. I AM VERY PROUD TO
BECOME COME FROM A DISTRICT
THAT HAS TO. ASIAN COMMUNITIES
ARE SO SIGNIFICANT THAT WE
CELEBRATE THESE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY MAKE THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY LIVE
MUCH BETTER AND- THEY I DON'T
THEY'VE COME TO IDENTIFY THESE
AREAS AND PEOPLE GO THERE
SIMPLY TO VISIT. WHAT THESE-
ASIAN COMMUNITY PROVIDE TO THIS
AREA NATIONAL CITY I HAVE ONE
OF THE LARGEST FILIPINO
COMMUNITIES AND- IN AND THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AN IMPRINT
IMPERIAL COUNTY. WE HAVE A
CHINESE COMMUNITY IN MAKING
KILEY KINDA COME SPILLS OVER
INTO- CALEXICO PUT. AN
INTERPRETER COUNTY BUT IT'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE GOES TO MAKE IT
CURLY SPECIFICALLY. TO TASTE
THE FOOD AND TO ENJOY THE
CULTURE THAT THE- EIGHT ASIANS
ARE THE CHINESE AND THE
COMMUNITY CONTRIBUTE TO- THE
CITY OF MEXICALI AND IT'S MADE
A VERY FAMOUS. AND THAT'S
WONDERFUL THING. TO HAVE PEOPLE
TO CONTRIBUTE SOMETHING TO THE
POINT THAT. IT MAKES THOSE
AREAS NOTABLE ATTRACTIVE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
CELEBRATE. IN INCOME IN
CALIFORNIA CELEBRATE OUR
DIFFERENCES CELEBRATE. THE
WONDER IT IS TO HAVE PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
CONVERGING CONTRIBUTE. TO
FINDING NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AND BUSINESS
AND INNOVATION IN ALL AREAS. SO
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATE THE
CENTER- FROM FROM IRVINE
BRINGING MEASURE FORWARD PICKED
AND WE ALL NEED TO STAND.
UNITED TODAY AND REMEMBER THAT
WHEN EVER. THERE WAS. A
CHALLENGE FOR AMERICA. THURMOND
COMING TOGETHER IN A UNITED WAY
TO CONFRONT THE EXPANSION OF
THE NOT NOT SEE. AND PRINCIPLES
IN EUROPE AND- AMERICA UNITED
AND- PUT ASIDE OUR DIFFERENCES
AND EVERYBODY WENT TO DEFEND
OUR COUNTRY IN THAT TIME AND IT
HAPPENED IN DIFFERENT TIMES
DURING THE CIVIL WAR DURING
WORLD WAR TWO WHEN OUR COUNTRY
UNITES WE MAKE GREAT THINGS
HAPPEN AND IT'S A TIME FOR US
ON THIS ISSUE TO ME GOOD NIGHT.
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE THAT WE
SUPPORTED EACH OTHER WE VALUE
OUR OUR OUR DIFFERENCES AND
THEY MAKE US BETTER AND I URGE
ALL OF US ON THE FLOOR TO TODAY
TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF A START
TWELVE AND STAND UNITED AS
CALIFORNIANS. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MANAFORT TEMP- AT I
ALSO RISE ON BEHALF OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS BUT I ALSO RISE AS A
SOCIAL WORKER JUST TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. WHAT HAPPENS
THAT SOMEBODY CAN THINK. THAT
THEIR DISCOMFORT GIVES THEM THE
RIGHT. TO TAKE SOMEBODY ELSE'S
COMFORT TO TAKE SOMEBODY ELSE'S
LIFE. YOU SEE THAT IF YOU'RE
WORKING WITH INDIVIDUALS WITH
DOMESTIC SOMEBODY WHO ABUSES
THEIR SPOUSE. MUST ONLY GOING
TO DO THAT WHEN THEY PUT THAT
PERSON LOWER THAN THEM WHEN
THAT PERSON IS LESS IMPORTANT
THAN THEY ARE. CAN THEY BEGIN
THEN TO STRIKE OUT SOMEHOW TO
MAKE THEMSELVES FEEL BETTER TO
MAKE THEMSELVES FEEL BETTER IF
THEY COULD PUSH SOMEBODY ELSE
DOWN IF THEY COULD HURT
SOMEBODY ELSE. THIS IS THE SAME
THING OUR SAYING INTERNAL- THAT
INTERNAL INADEQUACY THAT
INTERNAL ANGER THAT INTERNAL
BLAMING LOOKING FOR SOMEONE TO
BLAME. FOR WHERE YOU FIND
YOURSELF IN LIFE. AND WE SEE
THAT OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. WE IDENTIFY ANOTHER
GROUP THAT YOU COULD SPEAK DOWN
ABOUT THAT YOU CAN TELL JOKES
ABOUT WITH YOUR FRIENDS AND
PEOPLE DON'T CALL YOU ON IT.
AND THEN WE SEE IT LEAD TO THIS
ULTIMATE ACTS OF VIOLENCE.
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE WE NEED TO
ROOT OUT AT EVERY. STEP WE CAN.
TO BE ABLE TO. TO IF YOU HEAR A
JOKE TO SPEAK AGAINST IT
BECAUSE THE ACT OF WHAT
SOMEBODY IS DOING. IS TAKING
THEIR OWN INTERNALIZED
INADEQUACY TO PROJECT ON TO
SOMEBODY ELSE. TO MAKE THEM
OKAY TO HURT THAT PERSON. AND
AS THE SENATOR FROM. SANTA ANA
SAID. IF WE DON'T SPEAK OUT
AGAINST IT THEY THINK WE WALK
WITH THEM. THEY THINK WE THINK
THE SAME AS THEY DO THEY THINK
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS OKAY AND
SOMEHOW MAKES ALL OF US WHO
FEEL THAT WAY. BIGGER AND
BETTER. MAKE SAYS WORSE IT
MAKES A SMALL. I THINK ABOUT IT
THREE SAID WAS LIKE A CANCER I
THINK OF IT I'VE BEEN OUT
WORKING IN MY YARD IN THE
SPRING OF A SPLINTER THAT
SPLINTER YOU GET UNDER YOUR
SKIN THAT FESTERS IS INFECTED
AND IT MUST BE TAKEN OUT. AND
WE TAKE IT OUT AND IT'S PAINFUL
TO GET IT OUT BUT YOU HAVE TO
CALL IT FOR WHAT IT IS. AND YOU
HAVE TO ACT. MANY OF US GREW UP
IN A TIME WHEN OUR- OUR OUR
GRANDFATHERS ARE ORDERED. DADS
THEY WENT AND FOUGHT. IN THE
GREATEST GENERATION. TO STAMP
OUT THIS KIND OF HATRED THAT
ALLOWS YOU. TO PUT SIX MILLION
PEOPLE INTO A CONCENTRATION
CAMP BECAUSE THEY ARE LESS THAN
YOU. IN THEIR VERY BEING
THREATENED SOMEHOW. YOUR VERY
BEING. WE SAID NO TO THAT AND
YET WE SEE. IT HAPPENING HERE
ON OUR OWN COUNTRY. WE MUST SAY
NO WE CANNOT LET THE WORK OF
THE GREATEST GENERATION WITHOUT
WE PUT AWAY FOR EVER. KEEPING
RISING UP IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
IS A SYMBOL. OF FREEDOM THE
SYMBOL OF EMBRACING OF
IMMIGRANTS. SPEAK OUT AGAINST.
DON'T LET SOMEBODY ELSE'S
INADEQUACY. DEFINE OUR COUNTRY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON S. R. TWELVE. SENATOR
RUBIO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE SENATE TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S. HARD TWELVE. I
STAND WITH THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND THE ASIAN
IMMIGRANTS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
YESTERDAY'S HORRIFIC MURDERS OF
EIGHT PEOPLE ARE JUST THE
LATEST ATTACK ON OUR ASIAN
AMERICANS AND ASIAN IMMIGRANTS
IN THE UNITED STATES AND ENOUGH
IS ENOUGH. REGARDLESS OF MODE
OF THEIR API COMMUNITY IS UNDER
ASSAULT. THEY'RE BEING PUBLICLY
INSULTED. BEATEN IN THE STREETS.
AND TIME BASED ON WHO THEY ARE
AND THEIR PLACE OF ORIGIN I SEE
MY FAMILY AND THESE VICTIMS AS
AN IMMIGRANT I AM HEARTBROKEN
TO SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THIS COUNTRY. THE DISTURBING
RHETORIC COMING FROM THE
HIGHEST OFFICE MUST STOP
BLAMING A GROUP OF IMMIGRANTS
FOR THE VIRUS COLLEEN ANOTHER
MINORITY GROUPS CRIMINALS AND
RAPISTS NONE OF THAT HAS A
PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY. IT'S THAT
IGNORANT ATTITUDE THAT
REINFORCES THE IDEA THAT THEIR
LIVES LIVES WERE EXPENDABLE.
AND THAT THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES
WERE AN EXCUSE AND A REASON TO
BE MURDERED. THIS HAS ALL THE
MARKINGS OF AN ACT OF. FEMICIDE
I STAND WITH THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND THE ASIAN
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR MOMENT OF
GRIEF AND I HOPE THAT EVERYONE
HERE AND EVERYONE LISTENING
STANDS WITH THE VICTIMS AS WELL
AS WE REFLECT ON THIS TRAGIC
EPISODE IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
TO VICTIMS OF HATE CRIMES AND
THE FAMILIES READING. WE VALUE.
WE STAND WITH YOU. AND WE WILL
FIGHT TO MAKE THE STOCK. I WANT
TO DATE THE GREAT SENATOR FROM
IRVINE FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND I URGE YOUR
ARTICLE THANK YOU. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE QUICKLY TO
CONDEMN- THE HATRED AND
VIOLENCE AGAINST THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY BUT
ALSO RISE TO POINT OUT TO-
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEALING WITH THE FEAR- I HAD A
YOUNG PERSON CALL ME YESTERDAY-
KOREAN AMERICAN WHO SAID. I
CAN'T FUNCTION TODAY. I FEEL SO
MUCH FEAR AND ANGER THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO I DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO TURN. AND THERE
ARE HE'S NOT ALONE. SO THOSE
ASIAN AMERICANS ASIAN
CALIFORNIANS WHO WONDER IF
THEY'RE GOING TO FACE THIS
HATRED AS THEY GO TO WORK THEY
GO TO SCHOOL THEY GONNA PLAY
NEED TO BE ON OUR MINDS AS WELL
AND SO I JUST WANT TO RISE IN
SOLIDARITY AND THANK THE
AUTHORS OF S. R. TWELVE AND-
STRONGLY URGE AND I BOTH.
SENATOR KAMLAGER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IN SOLIDARITY.
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE API
COMMUNITY AN URGENT AYE VOTE ON
S. R. TWELVE. I WILL BE VERY
SHORT BECAUSE THERE WERE SO
MANY. ELOQUENT COMMENTS MADE-
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY. A QUOTE
THAT STAYS WITH ME ALWAYS. IS
ONE WRITTEN BY JAMES BALDWIN TO
ANGELA DAVIS WHEN SHE WAS IN
JAIL. AND I QUOTE HE WROTE TO
HER SAYS. THEY WILL COME FOR ME
IN THE MORNING. IF THEY CAME
FOR YOU LAST NIGHT. WE HAVE GOT
TO STAND IN SOLIDARITY AGAINST
HATE. BIGOTRY RACISM MISOGYNY
AND SILENCE. BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT KILLS US THAT IS WHAT
DESENSITIZES US AND THAT IS
WHAT POLARIZES US AND KEEPS US
FROM STANDING FIRMLY AND WITH
COURAGE. WHEN MEMBERS. OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHEN OUR NEIGHBORS
WHEN OUR FAMILIES WHEN OUR
FRIENDS ARE KILLED OR MURDERED.
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN. BECAUSE OF THEIR
ETHNICITY BECAUSE OF THEIR
RELIGION. BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE.
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER. AND
BECAUSE OF SOMEONE ELSE'S
IGNORANCE. I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT S. R. TWELVE THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR MENU MAY
CONCLUDE. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUROUTPOURING
OF SUPPORT- I DON'T KNOW IF ANY
OF YOU HAVE BEEN BULLIED. BY IF
YOU'VE BEEN BULLIED YOU KNOW
THAT THE HARDEST PART ABOUT.
THAT DYNAMIC IS WHEN OTHER
PEOPLE GOOD PEOPLE DON'T SPEAK
UP. AND RIGHT NOW I CAN TELL
YOU AND I THINK SEVERAL OF YOUR
MARK ON THIS ASIAN AMERICANS
FEEL SCARED AND THEY FEEL
ALONE. AND IF YOU TALK TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT IS WHAT
YOU'LL HEAR. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION BECAUSE IT
GIVES A CLEAR VOICE. TO THE
IDEA THAT WE ARE CONDEMNING
HATE WE'RE CONDEMNING ACTS OF
HATE AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
I BAKER FIVE PORGES HI BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTES THREE FIVE
DALLY. I DODD FIVE TORONTO.
EGGMAN I GLAZER. FIVE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH HI HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES HI
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE FIVE MILLION. I NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH.
HI PAN HI PORTANTINO I. ROSS.
FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN.
NUMBER HI WHAT KASKI HI WIENER
FIVE WELL I. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. TORONTO STERN.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO. BEGIN TO LIFT
THE CALL IF YOU COULD GET
YOURSELVES READY. WE ARE GOING
TO START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN S. B. NINETY FIVE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. LEYVA
FIVE RUBIO FIVE STERN. FIVE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT THE SET
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS PARK
OCCURRED IN. NEXT MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT. SIX PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. LEYVA. HI RUBIO I
STERN. FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN WHICH IS A ANOTHER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BATES PORCHES.
DALLY. JONES LEYVA FIVE NIELSEN.
BUT CHIRLA BOTH. RUBIO I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS ONE RAIMENT
ARE CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO SB SIXTY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. RUBIO I
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY TWO KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR HERTZBERG I UNDERSTAND
YOU ARE STANDING YES SIR. UNDER
PRIVILEGES THE FLOOR MADAM
PRESIDING OFFICER AND PRESIDENT
YOU MAY PROCEED. IN THE. SENATE
BODY IN WASHINGTON DC JUST A
FEW MOMENTS AGO ON A FIFTY TO
FORTY NINE VOTE THE UNITED
STATES SENATE JUST CONFIRMED
OUR OWN HEAVIER PESETA- TO-
SUPPORTERS HHS SECRETARY I
THINK YOU WITH A MAGNIFICENT
JOB HE SERVED IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN THE OTHER
HOUSE BUT WE ARE ONE BODY IS A
LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN NINETY
TO NINETEEN NINETY TWO BEFORE.
COMING TO CONGRESS AND THEN
THERE CERTAINLY IS YOU KNOW
SERVE JUST GREAT DISTINCTION AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA
AND NOW WILL BE A GREAT
RESOURCE OF HAVING A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPORTANT
ISSUES THAT HHSDEALS WITH FOR
ALL OF US IN ALL PARTS OF THE
CITY CALIFORNIA SO I JUST
THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS AN
IMPORTANT POINT TO RAISE
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THIS
HAPPENED IN THE LAST A FEW
MOMENTS THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
MAN PRESIDENT. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND I'M SMITH WE OFFER A
SENATE CONGRATULATIONS TO OUR
NEW SECRETARY OF H. SS. MOVING
ON TO THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS
CAN COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR BURGESS. THANK YOU A
VENTURE JUST WANT TO NOTIFY
THOSE WHO ARE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE AGRICULTURE THAT WE WILL
CONVENE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
IMMEDIATELY UPON ADJOURNMENT
THANK YOU. SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU ARE PRESIDENT- THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE
ON THE SENATE FLOOR AFTER THE
ADJOURNMENT OF THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE I JUST OUTSIDE
HOUSING COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF
YOU COULD BE PROBABLY ON THE
FLOOR BECAUSE WE HAVE TO ADOPT
RULES BEFORE WE START HEARING
BILLS. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
MOVING ON TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS THE TIME
FOR THE INTERNET MEMORIES
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS I
RISE. TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF HOT YOUR HERNANDEZ.
HAVE YOUR HERNANDEZ PASSED AWAY
ON JANUARY THIRTY ONE. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY THREE. BORN IN MEXICO
HERNANDEZ WAS A LONG TIME
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
COMMERCE IN MY DISTRICT. WHO
DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO HIS
COMMUNITY AND TO HIS FAMILY.
HAVE YOU EVER NANDED SURE DOES
THE TRAFFIC COMMISSIONER FOR
THE CITY OF COMMERCE. FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
AND SERVED AS VICE CHAIR
420-172-2020 HE WORKED AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR SENIORS AND
SUPPORTED MANY CIVIC
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
COMMERCE SENIOR CLUBS. MISTER
HERNANDEZ ALSO WORKED AS AN
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
VOLUNTEER AND EARNED THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OLDER AMERICAN
RECOGNITION AWARD IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THIS IS A HEAVY LOSS
FOR THE THIRTY SECOND SENATE
DISTRICT AND FOR THE CITY OF
COMMERCE. HE IS SURVIVED BY.
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE AGAIN NOR
AND HIS FAMILY FOR THESE
REASONS I ASKED TO JOIN IN HIS
MEMORY THANK ABOUT PRESIDENT.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
TO THE DESK SO THAT HE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORY ALIVE BY
THE SENATE THANK YOU. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENTS AND MEMBERS-
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF WENDY JO
CORDON WHO IS A FORMER. STAFFER
FOR THE STATE SENATE MY
COLLEAGUE AND PREDECESSOR JACK
SCOTT. SHE SERVED HIM WELL-
TWENTY PASSED AWAY AFTER A LONG
ILLNESS ON DECEMBER TWENTY
SECOND TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. SHE
WAS BORN AND RAISED IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY AND ATTENDED SAN
MARINO HIGH SCHOOL SHE RECEIVED
BOTH HER BA AND MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM UCLA IN FILM AND
TELEVISION. SHE BEGAN HER
TELEVISION CAREER AS A REPORTER
AND PRIORI ILLINOIS. AND SHE
WENT ON TO BE THE FIRST FEMALE
ANCHOR. OF K. O. I. N. T. V. IN
PORTLAND OREGON. SHE ALSO
HOSTED HER OWN TALK SHOW AND
SHE LATER JOINED K. H. J. NOW
K. CALLAN LOS ANGELES AS THE
EVENING NEWS ANCHOR IN NINETEEN
NINETY. BOLICK K. H. J. WHEN HE
RECEIVED TO LOS ANGELES AREA
EMMY AWARDS FOR INFORMATION
SERIES. IT WAS ALSO IN THIS
ROLE THAT SHE MET AND
INTERVIEWED A NOTED HIV AIDS
PHYSICIAN DOCTOR MICHAEL
GOTTLIEB. WHO SHE ULTIMATELY
MARRIED. AFTER HER RETIREMENT
FROM TELEVISION IN NINETEEN
NINETY SHE MANAGE PRESS
RELATIONS AS I SAID. FOR
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS
INCLUDING SENATOR JACK SCOTT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS HOLDEN
AND FINALLY SHE WORKED FOR ME
WHEN I WAS IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. WHEN HE WAS A KIND
THOUGHTFUL HONEST A BREATH OF
FRESH AIR HELLO LARRY IS A POOL
AND TWO HER YOUNGER COLLEAGUES.
SHE WAS A SPECIAL PERSON. WHEN
HE WAS A WONDERFUL PHENOMENAL
WOMAN WHO DIDN'T FOLLOW BUT
LET. SHE COULD DO ANYTHING AND
LEFT AN IMPRESSION IMPRESSIVE
MARK ON THE WORLD. SHE WILL BE
MISSED DEARLY BY THOSE WHO ALL
WHO KNEW HER. HER HOME WAS
ALWAYS WELCOME AND A PLACE FOR
COMMUNITYAND POLITICAL EVENTS
WHERE SHE GENEROUSLY HER
GENEROUS SPIRIT. AND PERSONAL
PASSION SUPPORTED MANY MANY
LAUDABLE LOCAL CLASSES. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER LOVING HUSBAND
ANOTHER GOOD FRIEND DOCTOR
MICHAEL GOTTLIEB. HER DAUGHTER
WHO SHE WAS EXTREMELY PROUD OF
WE GOT HER WHAT WHITE COAT
RECENTLY AS DR JILL GORDON.
GOTTLIEB SHE HAS A TWIN BROTHER
JOHN GORDON AND A SISTER SUSAN.
ALMOST TWENTY AND PLEASE JOIN
ME SENATE COLLEAGUES. IN THE
JOURNAL IN HER MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU. PLEASE BRING YOUR
NAME TO THE DEATH SO THAT WE
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY MEMORY
ALIVE HER. SENATOR WIENER. BUT
THANK YOU. SEVEN THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES
IT'S A GREAT SADNESS THAT I
RISE TO ASK THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF ANNA
HALL STEAD- CIVIL SERVANT
ACTIVIST AND A GREAT LEADER FOR
DECADES IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY. AND HAD A
DISTINGUISHED HISTORY OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT SERVING ON COUNTLESS
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE. AND BOTH
MEMBER AND LEADERSHIP ROLES
INCLUDING THE SAN FRANCISCO
REDEVELOPMENT COMMISSION THE
SAN FRANCISCO PORT COMMISSION
THE TREASURE ISLAND DEVELOPMENT
AUTHORITY- FIFTEEN YEAR TENURE
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE BAY
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION. FAN FOR TWELVE
YEARS AS A MEMBER OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN THE LAST ROLE IN
THE MCC I HAD THE HONOR OF
SERVING- WITH AN ADJUSTED- THE
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE AND THE
SENATOR- FROM NAPA- THIS IS
VERY PERSONAL FOR ALL OF US AND
WAS JUST AN EXTRAORDINARY HUMAN
BEING A LEADER IS A HUGE LOSS.
FOR FORTY YEARS AND WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED AS A LONGTIME BOARD
MEMBER AND BOARD CHAIR OF SPUR
ON A NONPROFIT PUBLIC POLICY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
CREATING SOLUTIONS FOR PROBLEMS
IN THE BAY AREA- THERE IS NOT A
SINGLE MAJOR SPUR PROJECT BUT
ANALYSTS NOT SOMEHOW. INVOLVED
WITH. FURTHERMORE AND DEDICATED
HERSELF TO COMMUNITY
NEIGHBORHOOD OF VOLUNTEER
GROUPS SERVING ON THE BOARDS OF
MANY MANY ORGANIZATIONS- FOR
EXAMPLE PEOPLE FOR OPEN SPACE-
CHINATOWN COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. AND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD PARKS COUNCIL. I
DID ORGANISE AND HELP TO GUIDE
THE DECISION MAKING. WITH A
POWERFUL EMPHASIS ON RACIAL AND
GENDER EQUITY ALLEN WAS
REVERED AS A GIANT IN HER FIELD
AND HER COMMUNITY DUE TO HER
SUCCESS INVESTIBLE ONES AS WELL
AS HER MODESTY SENSIBILITY AND
COMMITMENT TO MENTORING YOUNG
WOMEN. DANCING DAYS BEEN
SPURRED BOTH INSTITUTIONAL AND
PHYSICAL CHANGES IN THE BAY
AREA. WETHERBY THE NUMBER OF
PARKS IN THE CITY THAT SHE
FOUGHT TO DEVELOP AND MAINTAIN.
THE SAN FRANCISCO CITY CHARTER
THAT GOVERNS THE CITY TODAY OR
THE ORGANIZATION SHE HELPED
LEAD AND STRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
HER CAREER. AT WHOLE SAYS
IMPACT IS VISIBLE THROUGHOUT
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO TRULY GET
YOUR HEAD AROUND HOW MUCH THIS
AMAZING HUMAN BEING DID FOR OUR
CITY OVER SO MANY YEARS I AM
PASSED AWAY. JUST THIS PAST
WEEK HOWEVER HER LEGACY WILL
NEVER BE FORGOTTEN BY THE
PEOPLE SAN FRANCISCO INCLUDING
THE ONES WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO
SHE WAS BECAUSE THEY WILL
EXPERIENCE HER CONTRIBUTIONS
EVERY DAY. PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY
AND TURNING- THE SENATE AND.
THE MEMORY OF ANNA HALL SAID.
PLEASE BRING HER NAY FOR TO
DESK SO THAT SHE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATORS I NEED TO CORRECT AN
ITEM ITEM NUMBER TWELVE- I MAY
MAY I MAY HAVE MISSPOKE THERE
WERE THIRTY SEVEN ICE AND
SERONO'S ON THAT ITEM. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LET
ME AGAIN WISH A WONDERFUL
BIRTHDAY TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD. HI AND ALSO TO
EVERYONE I HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY MARCH
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT TWO PM THANK YOU. SENATORS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY. PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM.